rosa pérez más de una revista de prensa
de hoy viernes ya estaban preguntando
los televidentes que dónde estaba usted
pues aquí está solamente movimos un poco
la sección por lo que teníamos deporte
sin invitada y vamos a empezar esta
revista de prensa rosa con una noticia
última hora sobre el asesinato de la
periodista al yazira en israel el
setting abu a clay buenos días raúl
exactamente no hemos conocido que
naciones unidas se suma a la lista de
organizaciones que han llevado a cabo
investigaciones independientes sobre el
asesinato de la periodista de al yazira
sin agua que mientras con un grupo de
periodistas cubría una redada del
ejército de israel a un campo de
refugiados en cisjordania el 11 de mayo
bien naciones unidas señala que a la
periodista la mató el ejército israelí
así como pues también lo había señalado
previamente como decíamos tanto berlín
cat como el washington post como el new
york times o 'associated press' y además
señala naciones unidas así como las
otras investigaciones que no había
palestinos armados en las inmediaciones
del grupo de periodistas por lo que el
ejército israelí habría confundido al
grupo de prensa con combatientes
palestinos algo que habían ha señalado
también pues los distintos testigos de
los hechos que además insisten así como
naciones unidas en que la prensa se
había identificado ante pues el convoy
de israel y nos quedamos o con al yazira
que se hace eco de las protestas que
están actualmente activas en ecuador'
exactamente estas protestas que ya van
por su día número 12 no hay que
continúan pues a tomándose las calles de
ecuador señala al yazira que pues el
motivo no pues de el alza de la coste de
la vida y con exigencias no pues para
que haya mayor inversión pública en
ámbitos como la sanidad o la educación o
unas protestas lideradas por los pueblos
indígenas que además señalan a que no
van a cesar con estas manifestaciones
hasta que pues vean a sus exigencias
resueltas pero nos da una serie de datos
este artículo de al yazira como que unas
14.000 personas participan en estas
protestas en las que ya ha habido tres
muertos noventa y dos heridos y 94
detenciones y siempre es interesante ver
como la prensa internacional pues
describe y resume la situación de otro
país y en este caso este artículo señala
que pues el petróleo y las flores son
los principales productos de exportación
de ecuador y describe ecuador como un
pequeño país sudamericano plagado de
tráfico de drogas y su consecuente
violencia se ha visto muy afectado por
el aumento de la inflación el desempleo
y la pobreza todo esto exacerbado por la
pandemia rosa y en relación al informe
de digital news un poder que
comentábamos el día de ayer del
instituto reuters una de las claves que
es que aumenta sobre todo en los jóvenes
el porcentaje que evita voluntariamente
estar al corriente de las noticias y en
una pues una clave una conclusión pues
bien interesante no porque vemos como
este estudio analizó en 2017 2019 y 2022
el porcentaje de personas que dicen
evitar voluntariamente estar al
corriente de la actualidad y de las
noticias vemos el primer gráfico en azul
en la proporción de personas que
evitaban activamente las noticias en
2017 en naranja las cifras respecto al
2019 y en violeta las del 2022 y vemos
que en todos los casos estas esta
proporción de personas que no quieren
saber las noticias aumenta pero sobre
todo es destacable este aumento en
brasil que encabeza no esta
clasificación prácticamente se duplica
el número de personas pues que no
quieren saber nada de la actualidad en
este país pero por otro lado es
importante comentar las razones por las
que la gente dice que no quiere estar al
corriente de la actualidad por un lado
la primera es que hay demasiada
información sobre kobe está algo que sin
duda pues ya va un poco de capa caída o
eso esperamos claro por otro lado
personas que declaran que las noticias
tienen un impacto negativo sobre su
humor no es decir pues que todos los
problemas que hay en el mundo pues
afectan digamos negativamente a las
personas bueno pues claro por otro lado
dice hay gente que dice que está agotada
por la cantidad de noticias que hay un
poco pues toda esta es sobre información
sobre todo tan característica pues del
panorama mediático digital por otro lado
hay gente que dice que considera que las
noticias ya no son de confianza o pues
que están sesgadas políticamente otra
gente que dice que provocan discusiones
que prefieren evitar pero no sé tú raúl
yo prefiero saber lo que piensa la gente
con la que interactúa y que está a mi
alrededor y por otro lado pues una
postura más derrotista que es que hay
gente que dice que siente que no puede
hacer nada al respecto de los problemas
pues que que se comentan en las noticias
y sólo para para terminar con esto es
importante destacar que de las personas
que consideran que las noticias no son
de confianza o que están sesgadas la
mayoría son personas que se consideran a
sí mismo de derechas como vemos en este
último gráfico no pues es un sentimiento
esto más extendido entre la derecha la
desconfianza versus los medios de
comunicación rosa muchísimas gracias
como siempre por la revista el día de
hoy viernes vamos el día del lunes con
más por supuesto de revista de prensa
nosotros continuamos esto es directo
américa
[Música]